Let's go next to our caller from the eight
three to area code, who is calling today from
eight three to.
Hello.
Yes, it is whose's.
This is Ruben from Houston.
Ruben from Houston, what's going on?
Right.
So I had two questions.
And mostly it's just a, you know, orient myself
a little better or, you know, understand,
you know, expectations.
So with with the death of Supreme Court justice,
there's been a lot of alarm sounding, I'm
sure.
And I just I just want to know why it appears
we won't go out to stop it or, you know, we
are very limited options.
Yeah, but if if if they do appoint a Supreme
Court justice, is it really I mean, I know
it's it's pretty bad and it's a shame that
it would happen, but is it really that bad?
Say, if we take this on it and, you know,
get the president elected with it, it's two
different things.
OK.
That's the thing.
So.
So, Ruben, it's two different things.
The things that are bad about a six to three
conservative court are different things than
what a Democratic Senate can prevent.
And so, for example, if you get a six three
conservative Supreme Court, you'll start to
see a really strict restrictions on abortion
passed at the state level, which will be challenged
in local courts, appealed to federal courts
and ultimately to the Supreme Court.
And the Supreme Court could issue rulings
which set new precedent, which dramatically
clamps down on abortion rights as an example.
That has nothing to do with Democrats taking
the Senate.
You understand?
So we're talking about both.
Taking the Senate is a huge importance.
But the appointed for life Supreme Court,
which could go six three, right conservative
is a whole slate of problems that have nothing
to do with the Senate.
All right, right.
I mean, I recognize that it's just that it
seems like.
I mean, obviously, for us, it's just that
we don't hear in the media when a Supreme
Court decision really affects anything except
for every once in a while.
I'm not sure what else they're like.
You know, I don't know that I agree with don't.
I mean, listen, I think maybe people don't
pay attention, but if you look over the last
year, you know, very important rulings with
regard to Obamacare, commerce related rulings
that affect how business is done, stuff about
business discrimination, really important
writings about corporate power.
I mean, I think people don't read necessarily
understand how those decisions linked to their
everyday lives.
It's just that it's just that you said you
only mentioned abortion and that that is something
that I am pro pro-choice, but it's just I
guess I never think about like health care
and things like that.
Yeah.
All right.
So second question is, so I made the mistake
of donating to, like, presidential election
campaigns like like Biden.
I mean, it's hardly a mistake.
It's just like now they're hounding me all
the time and I'm getting ads for her, you
know, for donating to, you know, senators
and just people running against Republicans.
And I wanted to ask, is that actually helpful?
Like, how how how much use is that money going
to go towards, you know, making the country
a better place?
Well, those are two questions.
Is donating helpful to get people elected?
The candidate who raises more money tends
to win all else being equal.
So, yeah, it does help people get elected.
Whether they will improve the country once
elected is a much more detailed and deep question
that probably exceeds our time today.
But, yes, that money does help get people
elected.
By the way, I've never donated to anybody
and I get the same ads, so I don't know how
much of it is.
Just everybody is getting ads right now.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I guess what they just saying politically
involved.
Right.
That happens.
Yeah.
OK.
Well, thank you very much for your answers.
And I really I really do think you're doing
a good thing again.
Thank you.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Terrific to hear from you.
We are going to go to a break.
My apologies.
I was not able to take every phone call, but
I do the best I can.
Quick break.
Back after this.